québec a déployé plus de 1000 agents de
prévention sur le terrain pour lutter
contre la coved 19 des équipes vont se
promener partout au québec pour informer
pour sensibiliser les employeurs et les
travailleurs sur les normes sanitaires à
mettre en place pour réduire la
propagation du virus
l'objectif est de visiter plus de 200
mille entreprises avec nous se fit
mongeon avocate spécialisée en droit du
travail chez des roches mongeon avocat
bonsoir ce fut mon jean ensemble quelles
seront les tâches de ces agents de
prévention dans les milieux de travail
mais si solide enfants les agents de
prévention existent depuis un certain
temps c'est très commun dans l'est dans
le domaine de construction dans le fond
l'agent de prévention c'est comme des
yeux du maître d'oeuvre donc est le
maître de chantier donc lui son objectif
c'est de regarder avec sur le terrain
voir ce que des problèmes quelconques et
on peut apporter
allez les défauts en santé sécurité et
c'est donc en principe c'est à challuy
sont s'assurer que toutes les règles en
santé sécurité sont villes observées ok
mais ce ne sont pas des inspecteurs à
proprement parler ils peuvent pas
ordonnée par exemple la fermeture d'un
lieu jugé non sécuritaires non ils
peuvent pas faire ce genre d'exercice là
donc ils peuvent tout simplement le dire
à la personne concernée sur le chantier
et à ce moment là si le danger est réel
et pau direct que leur éducation plus
rapidement à ce moment là un inspecteur
ans un ancien nécessité vont être
vraiment déçu sur les lieux à ce moment
là pour prendre les actions nécessaires
qui sont graves
ok et lov moment là est ce que la cnss t
pourrait forcer la fermeture d'un lieu
et faire en sorte que les employés
soient renvoyés à la maison
oui il pourrait forcer la fermeture d'un
chantier qui retourne et les gens chez
eux de la question qu'on doit se poser
c'est qu'une fermeture de chantiers qui
paye les travailleurs à ce moment là
leur fille qui perd les travailleurs ont
pensé la sioniste est ch'ti qui met un
terme à qui ferment chantier à ce moment
là le travail est réputé d'être au
travail
en principe c'est l'employeur qui paye
mais là aussi la fermeture est faite par
autre personne que les sionistes qui met
en principe si les travailleurs sont
retournés chez eux
la grande question qui paye les
travailleurs actuellement sur le terrain
ce qu'on espère répondre c'est si par
exemple tu as été en contact avec
quelqu'un qui tue c'est positif
vous qui êtes infectés tu es tu fais
partie du cercle de cette personne ne se
retourne chez toi non le c'est sûr que
des positions un peu contradictoire par
rapport à aux travailleurs et aux
employeurs
c'est ce que les employeurs veulent que
travailleur pas su me demandant la
prestation canadienne d'urgence tandis
que les travailleurs eux s'ils sont
retournés au travail parce que dans le
cadre de leur travail sont exposés mais
en principe il devrait avoir accès aux
indemnités de remplacement de revenu au
même titre que cistella sioniste y avait
permis chantier d'accord et donc si
l'entreprise par exemple ferme de façon
préventive son plancher ou son chantier
pour renvoyer des employés à la maison
qui va payer ce moment là en principe si
celle-ci ne sait ce qu'il fait c'est
l'employeur si c'est l'employeur de son
propre chef qui décide de retourner ses
employés à la maison pour exercice qui
est obligé de faire de ces de prendre
les mesures nécessaires sur votre
l'article 51 de la loi sur la santé ce
qu'il dit rice et lui décident de donner
suite à ce qui vous retourne chez vous
et c'est là que le gros problème est que
le téléphone dérougi sans arrêt parce
que la question c'est qui qui paie pour
ça moi personnellement je veux inviter
les travailleurs à faire une réclamation
et le synesci commun et demander leur
prestation parce que n'eût été une
subtilité au travail et serait pas en
quarantaine chez eux
ok mais si c'est la pcu par exemple
qu'un travailleur va toucher c'est pas
pareil c'est pas la même chose pour
l'employeur du point de vue de
l'employeur c'est pas la même chose
parce que si c'est la cnss et l
employeur à un coût de ce côté là oui
très peu de gens comprennent un peu
quand même classé ne sait ce qui
fonctionne en france que si financée par
les fonds gouvernemental pas vraiment
c'est un point commun si vous me
permettez où les employant eu beau
mettre des sous c'est que si les
employeurs généralement qui finance les
sionistes et grossièrement si vous me
permettez pour le commun des mortels
c'est un peu comme nous assurons surtout
à nous le plus qu'on ait d'accident plus
nos primes augmentent donc pour un
emploi même chose plus que de travailler
en font des réclamations
les scénaristes et plus qu'elle est là
sioniste et verse des indemnités plus il
reçoit une facture se fait par exemple
pour chaque foot le shcc grossièrement
alors qu on comprend donc s'il a signé
ceux ci verse un dollar au travail à
l'employeur de recevoir une facture
environ d'un dollar week-ends ici pour
ce qu'il vaut beaucoup de contestations
parce que là et l'appui et le bit
prévoit des moyens pour leur dire écoute
moi ça me tente pas de payeurs de long
et 15
parce que c'est de ma faute
nécessairement tout ce qui se passe
un employeur qui pour qui ne veut pas
payer l'ensemble de la facture pour
évoquer un paquet d'affaires des
conditions préexistantes qu' il y avait
une tierce personne d'impliqué mais
aussi il peut évoquer un article qui est
exceptionnel s'appelle l'article 332 la
ra tmp moi j'ai vu juste 2 kozmus a été
plaidée par un employeur qu'est-ce que
cet article ça a été un mot qu une fois
pendant la crise du verglas si je me
trompe pas la crise du verglas 198 donc
à ce moment l'eau ce qui s'était passé
c'est un travailleur un monteur de ligne
avait été passé à l'état par une
entreprise et le monteur de ligne
s'était blessé donc en principe tous les
sous que le monteur de lignes reçu
l'employeur a reçu une facture en
conséquence mais lui dicte pas de ma
faute amoureux que cette recette à
travers le s'est blessé c'est à cause
d'une circonstance particulière donc
hilton qui est un désastre
donc là entre la tmp pardon le prix vu
la loi sur les accidents du travail
maladies professionnelles
un article particulier où l'emploi
pourrait dire waouh je ne veux pas payer
cette facture là parce que c'est un
désastre
peut-on les polices d'assurance en vous
savez des fois ils vont refuser pays
ales gard insurrection et ses ex époux
en arctique un peu spécial le qui
président la ratp
c'est pas simple quand même pas d'un bar
on est dans une situation complexe
le problème c'est qu'actuellement vous
savez le ministre bout à bout les a fait
beaucoup de démarches en voulant tout
changer la loi à l'automne donc avec ce
problème qui vient de ce parti ont
occasionné beaucoup tout la façon que la
ceni cystite est financée parce que
c'est un bon ça demande saas
encourage les contestations voilà parce
que chaque fois qu'on copie on reçoit
une facture alors sacré bon moment pour
revoir toute cette espèce de de
facturation et tout le financement de la
cinétique pour en attendant je souhaite
une bonne soirée sophie mangeons faut
s'arrêter
merci merci à vous